um mr beast
we just going to talk about more
what
because yeah yeah i want to make a joke
about this but
which
well you know it's going to be crazy
when you actually like
oh yeah i guess it's kind of weird to
joke about this right after
you know i'm just gonna let people fill
in the blanks so if he's recreating
squid games would be funny if you
actually
got rid of them when they lost
yeah so how much do you think he spent
on that uh go back to that
oh he said it right
now
um i mean where is that that's [ __ ]
ridiculous i would have to yeah like to
that scale seems like you're
i don't even know if an airplane hanger
would contain that that seems like the
size of an airplane hanger so i would
think it's got to be in like some
unused like event center and it's got
like on a field somewhere yeah if you
can't see the video for people that are
just listening
oh yeah yeah we're doing that again by
the way we we gotta stop alienating
sorry sorry audio audio only listeners
and actually uh out of respect for our
dedicated audio listeners who don't
always get to watch the video who are
maybe on their commute or something
we've decided the rest of those episodes
actually asmr just to treat you
yes special yes yeah whisper sweet
nothings to you for the next half hour
yeah
no so yeah sorry if you can't see this
video though for the audio only
listeners it's a video of a guy
microwaving vomit and then
oh come on tell them the truth
it's diarrhea in a cup
going into the oven
he's broiling it
he's trying to get like a caked layer of
diarrhea at the top of the cup
so it can kind of be like a shepherd's
pie of diarrhea
um no it's a guy with a beautiful shirt
on yeah microwaving a glow stick
pull over your beautiful shirt
no it's he mr beast is creating the
squid game set because he's he's doing
it with his fans i guess yeah so he's
he's building an actual practical set
where he's actually painting the walls
you know he's got like a [ __ ]
window washing crane and dudes are
painting this [ __ ] by hand and he's
gonna build that giant animatronic girl
too probably something of that effect
you know
damn the the scale of this bro i mean
this
this
like set right here i'm gonna just wager
250 grand minimum oh minimum yeah if not
more i like that to me feels like half a
mil just in labor
materials
everything yeah maybe even a million
dude yeah like that does not all those
[ __ ] like all those all these
construction
vehicles that he's renting yeah i was
thinking it would be in the millions
yeah the day then having to build that
[ __ ] robot and oh bro and there has
to be some sort of
motion control or motion detection
system too
yeah and then you have to supply all of
your guards with guns as well yeah that
part is gonna be crazy
i know this is inappropriate to joke
about right after yeah all the
astroworld stuff yeah it would be
kind of a funny concept
if he just he killed 500 fans
because mr b he's like the nicest guy in
the world yeah i know yeah he's got the
same [ __ ] team sees charity going on
right now he's trying to save the ocean
yeah and save the world and he's like oh
plus we're doing squid games for real
my kindness comes at a price
[Laughter]
oh that's not cool come on stop laughing
at that everyone that's not funny
it's pretty it's pretty funny it's not
funny it's pretty funny it's not funny
thinking about mr beast and his big old
smile
throwing someone in the ocean that's not
funny
look at all this trash we've we've
cleaned up
one must go
[Laughter]
all right enough enough enough
opium man let's talk about it yeah what
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man i've been i will say that we'll
save that
[Music]
my opium corner yeah this is just a
depressing episode so far yeah let's
talk about it honestly the past two
weeks has been like some bad [ __ ] yeah
honestly bad [ __ ] yeah two three weeks
has been oh you know what though
i did do a little bit of research on the
whole like bitcoin crypto
uh power draw thing and how it's bad for
the environment okay and the verb is
it's not uniquely shitty for the
environment it's just shitty
okay got it so
percentage-wise in terms of like you
know output and all that
uh
it
it's a lot but it
it doesn't i don't know what people's
concept in their mind is of how bad it
is relative to everything in the
environment
at present the
power draw of crypto is
the same as all of sri lanka
got it
so
people are arguing like or people's
sort of devil's advocate for that is
like
it's drawing enough power as a small
country but it's fueling a
technically a currency system
for millions of people yeah so
yeah you know
could you argue that it's somehow useful
i don't know um
i mean it's just like there was a
comment from some guy that was like it's
honestly [ __ ] hilarious to hear cody
talk about how
nfts are going to be clean and crypto is
going to be cl it's like
he he doesn't know anything
i know that web 3 is not going away yeah
weaponry's not going to go
it's either you know i think uh the
the biggest criticism i saw or like the
um
not biggest but
a really important criticism was
a lot of crypto farms claim that they
have
a renewable energy but there's no like
hard line for that so
you know what's interesting actually is
a lot of oil and gas companies they
naturally have leaks in gas and they
take advantage of that by they they're
creating like um mining
facilities out of those leaks like they
build on top of it and they power
they power crypto but it's like big oil
but they won't admit yeah
um like publicly that they're doing it
uh
because they like they don't want the
backlash but they're fully taking
advantage so that's kind of something
that's not the criticism i was getting
to that's kind of something to pay
attention to that your [ __ ] gas
company
is like silently trying to get in on
crypto by powering it so
there's there's there's that and then
um
yeah it's the part about renewable
energy where a crypto farm could
or a mining facility could be running
off of like gas and bad [ __ ] and then
have one solar-powered
you know
uh unit and then they're like yeah we
have renewable energy it's like well
yeah
sort of yeah so it's just generally bad
but there are bigger fish to fry yeah
like cars yeah
and planes
and planes yeah yeah
uh
but planes are sick though planes are
[ __ ] sick
so is krypto though yeah yeah
it is sorry
you